to answer the question and Paul so what
do you think do you think like um Andrew
Tate was better off messing around with
many women or just figuring just like if
you were still here he wasn't saying
wait wait but he wasn't saying like hey
guys get out there and cheat on your
wives like he wasn't saying that and
you're seeing that baby like guys don't
get married no he wasn't saying he did
not he was he was exclusively saying
stay away from shitty women stay away
from Trashy Women he's on record when he
was done when he was talking about the
milk boys right uh when they were
talking to him they were asking him
about like what do you want one of the
guys was saying like what do you want
like a woman who's inexperienced
sexually or a woman who has been through
a couple dudes and has more sexual
experience he's like what the hell kind
of questions and of course I want the
inexperienced woman right he is not
saying like get out there and hang out
with hoes and get out there and hoes are
the best thing he was saying like a good
pure decent woman is worth a masculine
protection from a worthy man